[Music]
david
is with us in chicago hi david welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hey good afternoon dave and chris it's
an absolute pleasure
absolutely how can we help brother hey
so i work for a large manufacturing
company
with locations throughout the u.s and i
aspire to be in management
and the company culture is to every
three to five years go to a different
division
and a different position and role and so
with that cadence
i am debt free but i'm looking to for
some guidance on
renting versus buying um as you're
you know climbing the ladder of a career
most of the time with a three to a five
year range you would buy
the only thing you don't want to do is
to buy in a market
where the i mean in a city where the
real estate market is stagnant
and so uh you know like for instance if
you're going in and you say well
i've got a four-year window at this city
uh you would ask the real estate agent
for
some indicators of how hot the market is
what's the in the neighborhood that i'm
looking in what's the dom the average
days on the market how fast does a house
sell
and if you hear 28 days then you've got
a real hot market
if you hear 280 days it takes nine
months no we're not
that's a slow stagnant market uh
in that case and the other thing you
want to ask them about is about
appreciation
during that time how much is the house
going to go up in value or how much of
homes in that area in that neighborhood
gone up in value
they can pull those stats from the mls
very quickly it's not hard to do
and and so if you've got usually they
run together by the way if you've got a
a real hot market and the houses sell
quickly then usually you have
a a good high appreciation the thing's
going up enough per year that you'll
make enough on the house to not only pay
the expenses but make a profit
uh and of course if you live there five
years then that's it if you ended up
changing jobs and staying then that's it
too so you're
you're owning the house the whole time
now if you're going to be there only two
years
you're going to find some markets where
you're not there enough to
house won't go up enough in value you'd
end up losing money selling it even if
it was a hot market
right yeah and david the other thing i'd
remind you to do and this is what's
gotten a lot of people into trouble
is as they buy a house and they move
because they're transferred
they try to hold on to that house and
then have it as a rental property
well again you don't want to go that
route so the thing i would tell you is
to make sure
if you are going to be there over that
two years or that three year window
just make sure you sell set house before
you move on to the next one
okay yeah that sounds good i've had that
idea before so that that clears that up
yeah very good man hey thank you for the
call that's some good good question